[Music]
foreign
so we've been talking about how to
approximate the derivative of a function
with respect to time or space using
these finite difference numerical
derivatives and so you know instead of
taking the limit as delta T goes to zero
we use a finite delta T because
computers you know can't take limits as
things goes to go to zero and this is
one example of an approximation of DF DT
called the central difference derivative
and the central difference derivative is
a pretty good one it has a good
error scaling meaning that this
expression approximates the derivative
and only has a little bit of error that
is proportional to Delta t squared which
means that
um
if I have you know if I if I cut delta T
in half my error goes down by a factor
of four if I decrease delta T by a
factor of 10 if I make delta T 10 times
smaller my error gets 100 times smaller
and so on and so forth so that's very
advantageous and so this begs the
question
why don't I just always make delta T as
small as possible especially if I'm
doing this numerically you know I have
some function and I'm just approximating
this numerically why wouldn't I always
just use the smallest Teensy in CS delta
T possible you know delta T equals 10 to
the minus 10 or 10 to the minus 100 okay
so the question is as
delta T goes to zero
does the error
become
arbitrarily small
arbitrarily
this is like a math word does it become
arbitrarily small
that's a really really interesting
question so mathematically yes
mathematically this error does go to
zero as delta T goes to zero but in
practice on a computer the answer is
absolutely not okay so the answer is no
an emphatic no on a computer if you do
this numerically
because
because uh the way that the computer
represents these numbers has something
called numerical roundoff and this is
because of numerical truncation error
numerical
truncation error
truncation error
which is sometimes called round off
error okay
round off error
round off error
so when you represent a number in a
computer like I type you know Pi or e or
square root of 2 in a computer
even though we know that those numbers
never end they never they have kind of a
an ever you know uh continuing sequence
of digits and decimals in their decimal
representation the computer has finite
memory and finite kind of bits to
represent each of those numbers and so
all of our computers agree on formats
for for how to store numbers using a
certain number of bits or bytes and one
of the kind of standard types of numbers
that we all agree on and use is called a
double Precision floating Point number
which you know it uses a certain number
of bytes which is you know eight bits
and so two to the eight
is 32 and is that right 2 to the 8 is 32
2 to the 5 is 32 2 to the 8 is uh 256 I
guess and you know with a couple of
bytes it's a few 256 times 256 times
256. my point is with a finite number of
bits or bytes on a computer you can only
represent a finite number of decimals uh
in any number okay and after that point
anything beyond that that decimal
representation gets truncated or rounded
off because it can only be stored using
those finite number of bits in a
computer
and so uh double Precision floating
Point numbers which is kind of the
standard for numerical computation you
know in most computers across the world
unless you specify otherwise the round
off error which I'm going to call the
error of roundoff I'm just defining the
symbol is about
10 to the minus 16. so this is a really
important number in computers at least
for double Precision for uh
double floating Point Precision we call
this double Precision numbers
um and I can't remember if this is
32-bit or 64-bit
I really should remember it's probably
32-bit
um but I you you could just Google you
know double Precision number bits and
you'll find it and actually not just
that you'll find the
um like the the standard of exactly how
the information is stored in those bits
so for example you know one of those
bits is for if it's plus or minus
um
a number of those bits are for this 16
you know decimal places of precision and
then a number of bits is for the
exponent you know some num plus or minus
some number times 10 to an exponent to a
power so that power will also require
some bits to represent
and so you can just Google you know
double Precision number format and you
can find all of that information but on
a modern computer probably even my you
know smart watch or your your phone or
whatever a lot of calculations are done
using double Precision math which
fundamentally has an error in all of its
representations of 10 to the minus 16.
okay and so specifically you can like
log you can get onto python or Matlab
and you can take some number like square
root of two
and you can I think say format long in
Matlab and it'll actually dump out all
16 digits of of this this representation
format long and then square root of two
and if you take square root of 2 plus
10 to the minus 16 over 2. you know this
ER over 2 something smaller than this
round off if you type this in
you know to Matlab or python it will
have the same
decimal double Precision representation
is if you just typed in square root of
two these are going to have the exact
same representation on your computer
which means that it can only specify
this number up to those 16 digits of
accuracy if I add something smaller than
10 to the minus 16 to this number your
computer can't tell the difference
between those okay and so this round off
error is going to factor in to this
numerical derivative error so there's
the error from the Taylor series but
there's also going to be an error from
the numerical round off and that's what
I want to show you today is how these
two balance and it actually makes it so
that at some point decreasing your your
delta T actually makes things worse okay
and that's kind of interesting
is there anything else I want to tell
you about double Precision uh obviously
I have a lot to say about this one thing
I'll tell you that is actually really
important is that numbers like square
root of 2 and E and Pi you know we know
that those have a rational
um
expansions and they go on forever even a
number like one-third is you know 0.3333
forever
the only numbers that will be perfectly
represented in double Precision are
numbers that have a
um an exact
non-repeating sequence in binary so if I
look at a number like uh you know 0.5
in binary that is literally in binary so
in binary which is what your computer
speaks this would be you know this is
one half so it's
0.1 in binary
it's it's 2 to the minus one it's one
and the two to the minus one's place in
binary so 0.5 is uh 0.1 in binary
and 0.1 in binary is exactly represented
with you know 16 digits I don't actually
need all of those 16 digits I just need
you know one digit and so this is exact
this has no round off error so so 0.5 or
0.25 or 0.125 have no round off error in
a computer because they have perfect
decimal representations that go on you
know that it's you know zeros forever
after so these numbers actually have no
error but if I generically work with a
generic number some you know F of T it
probably is not going to be a perfect
truncated binary number it's going to
have this double Precision round off
good okay so now what we're going to do
is we're going to take this expression
for DF DT and we're going to recognize
that each of these numbers here probably
have a little machine Precision round
off error so I can add an ER to each of
these numbers because in the computer
they're probably not going to be
represented perfectly
so let's do that so we have uh DF DT
but now in a computer this is equal to
and I'm just going to say equals because
I'm going to have this this Taylor
series error this is equal to F of you
know t plus delta T minus F of T minus
delta T
plus each of these has some error so two
machine errors
and these do add up these accumulate
additively which is a problem divided by
two delta T
plus my order Delta t squared
okay and so essentially what I can do is
I can now kind of
separate off this error and I have the
thing I want
and then two sources of error so this
equals you know the thing I was trying
to compute in the first place
uh you know minus F of T minus delta T
divided by 2 delta T 2 delta T
Plus
ER over delta T
plus order Delta t squared
and so maybe I'll just pick you know a
blue for this
and red for this
these are two different sources of error
this is Taylor series error Taylor
series
uh yeah Taylor series
error
and this is round off error this is
numerical representation error so this
is round off error
and there are ways of using more bits so
I think like 64 bits or 128 bits or 256
bits and getting you know quad Precision
or OCT Precision you could get higher
Precision that would take this up to 10
to the 32 or 10 to the 64. it's much
more expensive and it's not natively
supported on a lot of computing
architectures but you could make this ER
smaller this roundoff error smaller but
for all computers you're going to have
some round off error and now I hope you
can see at least kind of pictorially
that if I make delta T smaller it
definitely helps my Taylor series error
but I'm dividing by delta T here and so
the smaller I make delta T the larger I
make this round off error and so at some
point these are going to cross and at
some point by making this one smaller
I'm actually going to make this one
larger and when these equal each other
that's like the trade-off point where I
shouldn't make delta T any smaller
our error
and I'm just going to
um
I'm going to say like the absolute value
of our error because it could be plus or
minus and I don't want to think about
that the absolute value of our error is
going to be less than or equal
to this you know er divided by delta T
Plus
Delta t squared
and I'm going to add I'm going to write
down a term M over 6 that's M over 3
factorial because this order Delta t
squared
we actually know what the coefficient of
that error term was it was F double
Prime
uh I'm sorry it was F triple prime
Delta t squared over 3 factorial
so this m is a constant it's a constant
that we Define as the maximum value of f
triple prime
on this interval from you know T minus
delta T to t plus delta T so it's the
max F triple prime you know T minus
delta T
2 t plus delta T so this is kind of just
some math jargon you can pause and
really convince yourself based on the
Taylor series that you know it's not
just order Delta t squared there is
actually a coefficient on that error
term and it's F triple prime divided by
3 factorial F triple prime over six
and so this error is always bounded in
the worst case scenario where that F
triple prime is as big as it possibly
could be so the max of the absolute
value of f triple prime okay
um
that doesn't matter it's a number m is a
constant for all that I care about m is
a constant it's a number it might be big
it might be small but whatever it's a
constant and 6 is a number so now I have
a function e is a function of delta T
okay and so I'm just going to call this
e Max we're going to call this e the
maximum error and this is a function of
you know delta T so this is e Max of
delta T and so now what we're going to
try to do is we're actually going to try
to to optimize this so we can take the
partial derivative of e Max with respect
to delta T and set it equal to zero
because that's going to be you know
where we want to find the minimum error
here I'm going to draw a picture I think
pictures are nice
so let's say this is uh delta T
and
my Taylor series error does get smaller
and smaller and smaller
as delta T gets smaller and smaller and
smaller okay so as delta T goes to zero
so does my Taylor series error and kind
of this you know nice quadratic
function this is you know my order Delta
t squared
or my M Delta T6 Delta t squared over
six if you like
but my roundoff error is going to do
something like it's going to be 1 over
delta T it's going to be some constant
some really really teeny constant times
1 over delta T and so when delta T is
zero it's going to be infinity and this
you know very very small constant e to
the e e sub r divided by delta T when
delta T gets small eventually this is
going to get really really big
they so so the total error is the sum of
these two the total error is the sum of
these two which is roughly speaking
going to look
kind of like this shape here okay this
blue curve is my round off error
and this green curve is my my total
error so what we're trying to find is
we're trying to find that sweet spot
delta T we're trying to find this like
really really special delta T where if
we made delta T smaller until this point
our error does decrease because the
Taylor series error is decreasing but
before our error starts to increase
again because of our round off error
getting Amplified so this sweet spot
error here
um is you know is this is the error
uh there are some special delta T and
that is going to be the point where this
Emax has zero slope right that's how you
optimize functions to find the minimum
or maximum of a function is you would
take the derivative of this with respect
to delta T and set it equal to zero so
it has zero slope there
and so partial
emacs partial delta T I can take the
derivative of this with respect to delta
T and I get something like you know
minus e r over Delta t squared plus
delta T M over 3. we're setting that
equal to zero and so I move this guy
over and I multiply both sides by delta
T and I do some stuff and I find out
that
um
I'm going to get something like
I don't want to skip too many steps I'm
going to get something like delta T I'm
going to move this over here and
multiply both sides by Delta t squared
so I'm going to get a delta T cubed
equals e r 3er over n
3er over n so delta T equals root cubed
root of 3 e r over m
and you can assume that M let's just
assume that m is a constant that's one
that's like a stupid assumption but
order a magnitude this number is
probably you know it's not going to be a
bajillion and it's not going to be one
over a bajillion it's going to be order
one this is going to be this n is going
to be about one and three is about one
and so I'm really taking the cubed root
of my round off error 10 to the minus
16. that's the number that mostly drives
this optimization is how fast this round
off error grows and it's you know this
is kind of the relationship here and so
this is approximately equal to 10 to the
minus 16 to the one-third power which is
about
10 to the minus 5. so for a delta T of
about 10 to the minus 5 you can expect
my error to decrease until about 10 to
the minus 5 delta T and then for even
smaller delta T it's going to ramp back
up again because of this round off error
this is super cool you can really Act we
think about like what's happening in the
guts of your computer there's this
numerical round off error you can
actually compute you know what are the
terms of error how do they scale with
delta T and you can do these kind of
back of the envelope sketches of um of
how these things work now if I had a
system that had a really really high
third derivative it was a really jerky
system that's what third derivative is
called jerk
[Music]
this would be larger and I would have a
different delta T I might I might want
to decrease my delta T more because my
Taylor series error might be you know
shifted up okay or if I was working with
a single Precision so er was a bigger
number this round off error would be
shifted up and I'd need a bigger delta T
so you can kind of imagine and work
through what would happen here anyway I
thought this was really important for
you to see this because you might just
naively think that you can always make
delta T go to zero but at least in a
computer that's a bad idea because of
this balance of Taylor series error and
round off error okay thank you
[Music]